les petites murale britanniques sont
venus au canada entre les amis 1869 et
ils étaient environ cent mais en gros
pour les beatles étaient des enfants qui
étaient pauvres les orphelins des
enfants qui était abandonné l'idée
c'était qui serait dénaturer déplacer et
s'est installé avec des familles au
canada pour qu'il y ait une mairie il y
avait l'aspect de la révolution
industrielle où les familles ont
vraiment été affecté en grande bretagne
les familles ont commencé à être divisé
les gens à retravailler en dés les
enfants étaient négligées aller avec
toute sorte d'inquiétude par rapport à
la condition des enfants
alors ceux qui ont été envoyés au canada
ont été parqués à travers le pays
la plupart ont été installés en ontario
mais y en avait plusieurs
dans les prairies au québec la nouvelle
écosse vraiment à travers le pays que
plusieurs qui ont participé dans le
programme n'avait pas de choix
certaines qui en a qui ont profité qui
ont prospéré même bien d'autres qui ont
vécu des conditions très difficiles il y
avait de la bu et ont été forcés à
travailler de longues heures dans des
conditions difficiles
c'était pas des enfants qui étaient
accueillis comme enfant et ont été
accueillis comme travailleurs alors on
sait que c'est pas toujours une
situation idéale mais d'autres qui
parlent de qui ont parlé de leur
expérience et qui parle du fait qu'ils
étaient très heureux avec les familles
dont un avec lesquels ils ont été placés
[Musique]